[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
sur france 3 bourgogne les syndicats de
cheminots se retrouveront jeudi prochain
pour décider de déclencher ou non un
mouvement de grève contre la réforme du
gouvernement une réforme dont les
grandes lignes ont été présentées le 26
février dernier par edouard philippe le
premier ministre a annoncé un recours
aux ordonnances pour faire adopter avant
l'été une réforme de la sncf si les
petites lignes ne devrait finalement pas
être touché le statut d agent et lui
voué à disparaître alors quelles
réformes pour la sncf comment moderniser
l'entreprise et la préparer au mieux à
l'inévitable ouverture à la concurrence
comment poursuivre dans le même temps sa
mission d'aménagement du territoire et
de soutien à ces territoires éloignés
parfois des grandes métropoles
comment améliorer les services aux
clients et réduire son déficit
on en débat ce matin avec mes invités
didier martin bonjour je vous êtes
député la république en marche de
côte-d'or merci d'être avec nous michel
neugnot bonjourbonjour premier vice
président socialiste de la région
bourgogne franche comté en charge
notamment des transports
cédric journaux bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le président de l'afld note
bourgogne franche comté la fnts et la
fédération nationale des associations
des usagers de transport merci également
d'être là et dizy marc bonjour je vous
êtes l'un des responsables régionaux de
la cgt cheminots merci à tous les quatre
d'avoir accepté cette invitation vous
qui nous regarde et vous pouvez bien sûr
commenter cette émission en direct sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag dit
mme paul bourgogne avant de vous donner
la parole on va regarder ensemble ce que
contient cette réforme de la sncf voulue
par le gouvernement voici quelques
éléments en présentant la réforme de la
sncf le premier ministre a été direct
sans détour il dresse un tableau
accusateurs de la compagnie la situation
est alarmante pour ne pas dire intenable
les français qu'ils prennent ou non le
train paye de plus en plus cher
pour un service qui marche de moins en
moins bien premier chantier le statut
des cheminots qui est voué à disparaître
pour les nouvelles embauches il est
abandonné
les futurs salariés dépendront du code
du travail seuls les cheminots actuels
conserveront leur statut
autre changement la sncf sera
transformée en société nationale à
capitaux publics
en revanche contrairement
recommandations du rapport spinetta le
gouvernement abandonne le projet de
fermeture des petites lignes dans la
réforme
il n'est pas question des retraites mais
le premier ministre a confirmé que ce
sera pour 2019
avec la fin des régimes spéciaux la
réponse des syndicats est unanime ces
réformes sont inacceptables on va tout
droit au conflit on verra dans un
instant si le conflit est effectivement
inévitable didier martin avaient
représenté ici la majorité
présidentielle celle d' emmanuel macron
qu'il veut à tout prix faire cette
réforme est assez rapidement on a
entendu le premier ministre qui a des
mots quand même assez dur qu'est ce qui
va si mal
le constat il est partagé par les
usagers par les contribuables
c'est une belle entreprise qui a une
histoire mais qu'il faut absolument
réformer parce que il y à une ouverture
à la concurrence qui est prévue qui est
imposé par l'europe et nous devons
donner à cette entreprise aux usages et
aux cheminots les moyens d'affronter
cette ouverture à la concurrence et de
rendre un service performant pour tout
le monde et surtout les territoires
quand j'en viens d'entendre ghisi
marasme les propos sont durs on paye de
plus en plus cher et le service marche
de moins en moins bien dit edouard
philippe
est ce que vous voyez les choses comme
ça du côté la cgt cheminots ça
m'étonnerait là que les choses aillent
de moins en moins bien c'est une réalité
c'est un ressenti maintenant il faut en
chercher les causes autres que ça coûte
de plus en plus du fait que ça coûte
plus de plus en plus cher sur le statut
et un certain nombre de choses qui
viennent d'être évoqués mais je ne vois
pas en quoi la question ça coûte cher
par rapport à quoi
de quoi parle-t-on c'est ça le vrai le
véritable en ajoutant on n'y a pas de
concurrence donc on peut difficilement
comparer mais si on peut comparer par
rapport à d'autres modes de transport
combien la collectivité locale est elle
prête à mettre pour
le mode de transport par rapport au fer
par rapport à la route par exemple ça
c'est pas un certain moment si on
sectorise tous les débats au niveau des
transports effectivement ça va être un
peu compliqué il va falloir qu'on
regarde je rappelle juste qui a un il ya
eu un grenelle de l'environnement car
tracer des objectifs de report modal
je vais me rappelle aussi qu'il ya une
coop 21 dans laquelle la france était
très active sur laquelle un ministre en
exercice était le principal le principal
acteur mois là j'ai un certain moment ça
se fait ce sont des directives
politiques et derrière qu'est ce qu'un
pays la france 1 où l'europe est prête à
mettre pour que ce report modal soit
effectif là on pourra parler de
financement et en ce moment on nous en
donne des chiffres en valeur absolue
on relativise par rapport à rien
effectivement si on donne on lance des
milliards comme ça c'est un peu embêtant
oui mais les milliards justement
parlons-en michel neugnot 45 milliards
d'euros de dettes à la sncf
il faut absolument réformer cette
entreprise publique
enfin 45 milliards de dettes pour sncf
réseau leur soutien du réseau
j'aurais quand même par rapport à
extraits que vous avez donnée du ried
présentation par le président de la
république il faut corriger un de ces
propos c'est faux que il a dit les
français payent de plus en plus cher
ces prêts ministre il a dit oui il a dit
ça sauf que le transporter vers
notamment puisque je suis représentant
de la région bourgogne franche comté ont
été lus sachez donc le français paye de
moins en moins c'est-à-dire qu'ils
paient 30 % en 2002 du coût du service à
travers son billet il ne paye plus en
moyenne que 25%
par contre il ya un déséquilibre total
de l'ensemble des comptes les régions de
france disent clairement mais pas depuis
le dernier changement gouvernemental ça
fait une dizaine d'années qu'on alerte
l'état sur une situation
un modèle qui arrive à son terme qui
arrive à son terme
12 je suis nous sommes totalement
satisfaits que le débat public qu'est ce
que c'est une nécessité parce que le
train et la sncf est le bouc émissaire
de beaucoup de choses qui ne dépendent
pas d'elle on va y revenir bien sûr
j'aimerais entendre cette zone
représente ici les usagers même si à la
sncf on dit clients maintenant et depuis
déjà quelques années c'est des journaux
est-ce que entend client vous avez
l'impression que cette réforme et puis
on va rentrer dans le détail dans un
instant elle va permettre aux clients
j'ai pas que par exemple les trains
soient plus à l'heure où que les billets
sont moins chers or nous sommes très
attentifs nous le serons aussi à
l'avenir sur ce que propose le
gouvernement puisque ce qui compte
aujourd'hui pour l'usager c'est d'avoir
un train qui soit fiable avec un train à
l'heure un train confortable un train
rapide et c'est là tout l'intérêt du
mode ferroviaire par rapport aux autres
modes cc3 hémodialysés mans ces éléments
là qui font que le train est favorable
par rapport à un mode routier par
exemple
et il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on se pose
des questions quant à savoir ce que ce
deviendra le train aux alentours des
grandes agglomérations mais également
sur le type ligne alors on va y revenir
bien sûr notamment évidemment sur la
question des petites lignes qui
préoccupe beaucoup de monde on le sait
mais je vous propose d'en revenir à la
méthode d'abord celle des ordonnances du
choix des ordonnances didier martin je
me retourne encore vers vous faut-il
vraiment en passer par les ordonnances
est ce que c'est vraiment un moyen très
démocratique de faire avancer le dossier
y at il une urgence il ya une urgence
on vient de parler des chiffres on les a
pas donné 14 milliards d'euros c'est ce
que coûte le système ferroviaire
actuelle à la nation chaque année trois
milliards d'euros c'est de déficit de la
sncf globalement chaque année et 1,5
milliard d'euros par an c'est le coût de
la dette de la société et celle d'argent
il va aux banques il ne va pas au
service
donc il est temps quand même de prendre
les bonnes mesures
et là quatre axes dans ces mesures le
premier axe on peut commencer par celui
ci c'est changer le statut aujourd'hui
nous héritons de un système un petit peu
morcelé trois établissements publics
industriels et commerciaux
il
faire une société nationale intégrer les
six métiers des de la sncf des cheminots
les réseaux des gars de service voyageur
bref il faut intégrer tout cela dans une
même logique et dans une même je dirais
analyse de service aux autres de juin
didier martin mais la méthode c'est les
ordonnances vous n'auriez pas pu en
parler au parlement tout simplement
mais nous avons d'autant que vous
employez la procédure d'urgence
quasiment tout le temps en ce moment ça
prend pas non plus des - non non c'est
pas tout à fait exact il y a une face de
deux mois de concertation et de dialogue
comme ça c'est fait pour la réforme du
code du travail il y a eu une
habilitation donné par le barde
parlement après débat au gouvernement
pour ouvrir ces négociations
il reviendra chapitre par chapitre sur
chacun des axes devant le parlement et
nous verrons si nous pouvons légiférer à
ce moment là ou si nous autoriserons le
gouvernement à procéder par ordonnance
pour régler c'est le but du premier
ministre déploie technique les
ordonnances seront limités à des poids
technique michel leniaud les ordonnances
ça me choque pas marché aussi important
dans un jus 10 et un débat national qui
est nécessaire qu'il faut faire avec une
certaine sérénité
moi je ne voudrais pas que sur un sujet
aussi important pour l'avenir des
mobilités en france eh bien on
recommence l'erreur qu'avec est commise
par le gouvernement que je soutenais
avec le 49-3 sur la loi les conneries je
pense qu'il faut que la nation
s'emparent de ce débat il est trop
important et donc il faut pour la france
est donc il faut le temps par contre ce
qui est vrai ce qui est réel c'est que
nous devons en tout état de cause l'état
doit légiférer avant pour avoir une loi
ce prêt présentant les modalités
d'ouverture la concurrence avant la fin
de l'année donc il faut qu ils n
auraient établi avant la fin de l'année
avant vers décembre 2018 sur la
problématique de l'ouverture à la
concurrence 18 mois on a quand même le
sentiment même si didier martin n'a pas
dit sur ce plateau que le gouvernement
cherche à aller vite pour endiguer les
contestations la contestation que vous
pourriez mettre en place y compris par
un moyen de grève est ce que vous avez
ce sentiment est ce que vous le partagez
sait même pas que d'aller vite c'est un
problème de démocratie tout simplement
un certain moment on va parler le
ferroviaire sais pas c'est pas des
projets à deux ans ou trois ans ce sont
des projets à 50 ans l'avenir d'une
nation va pas se décider en deux mois
qu'ils ne sont pas des négociations et
jeu là je reprends m'inscris en faux
c'est pas des négociations sont des
concertations
on recueille les avis des uns et des
autres pour des ordonnances et pour un
cadre qui est déjà fixée le ministre
était clair il vous dit ça sert à rien
ce qui sert à rien on va pas changer
exactement à l'heure actuelle je ne sens
pas une volonté de débattre sur le fond
d orientation pour le système
ferroviaire pour la mobilité à 50 ans
dans ce pays et donc mais c'est pour le
ferroviaire comme pour d'autres sujets
qui viennent des traités on l'a bien vu
à travers ou lé wells où elle la
population où sont les avis la
population comment on répond un
véritable service public ferroviaire
pour les besoins de la population en 50
ans il n'y a pas de débat qui ont
réalisé les ordonnances ne peuvent en
aucun cas répondre à ça ensuite j'essaie
quand même dans les propos du premier
ministre
cette chiffon rouge affiche est là en
dix ans le statut faut le faut le
détruire parce que on a entendu 50
milliards de lettres dans le système ce
serait le statut le responsable j'ai un
certain moment au statut de l'entreprise
où je suis je suis non parce qu'on
l'aimé de a les deux justement et c'est
pas ça la cause elle est pas là la cause
n'est pas là donc on essaye de dire de
scinder les problématiques en disant
région ne vous inquiétez pas les petites
lignes on n'y touche pas en dix ans la
même chose aux associations d'usagers ne
vous inquiétez pas c'est pas remis en
cause et de l'autre côté
en dix ans les retraites nous c'est
pareil on remet ça l'an prochain lire en
gros et on dit à l'ensemble de la
population
regardez ces cheminots qui ont un statut
donc je crois qu'un certain moment le la
stratégie du gouvernement c'est une
stratégie de division de l'opinion
publique on lui montrant des choses
inintéressantes et on voit bien les
problèmes que ça pose en termes de
démocratie
didier martin à ce qu'on stigmatise les
cheminots parce que vous nous dites la
sncf ya quelques instants à la sncf perd
de l'argent
donc il faut changer le statut de
l'entreprise et le statut des cheminots
est ce que c'est vraiment ces deux
points là qu'ils vont faire faire des
économies à la sncf soyons francs le
statut de la sncf
il doit obligatoirement être révision
intégrer les trois fonctions les 3 epic
actuelle et intégrer les différents
métiers dans une seule société ça va pas
forcément faire valider à son public ce
qui va faire gagner de l'argent aussi
à propos du statut des cheminots qui
n'est pas un chiffon rouge qui
agité c'est simplement donner à la sncf
les moyens d'affronter la concurrence
on sait aujourd'hui que l'organisation
au sein de l'entreprise et les statuts
qui n'est pas le principal problème fait
perdre 30% de compétitivité à
l'entreprise quand on va ouvrir à la
concurrence que restera-t-il de parts de
marché dans notre marché national pour
la sncf c'est la question qui est posée
nous voulons donner à cette entreprise
les moyens d'y aller ça veut dire qu'on
pense que certains journaux l'ouverture
à la concurrence va mettre à mal la sncf
ce que vous pensez vraiment que sur
certaines lignes de la région par
exemple il y aura beaucoup de sociétés
qui vont se positionner pour remplacer
la sncf ont beaucoup je serais incapable
de vous répondre aujourd'hui puisque de
toute façon les appelle la concurrence
ne sont pas encore actée par la région
mais moi j'ai surtout une appréhension
sur l'évolution du mode ferrées en
france on fait actuellement en france à
trun bachini sncf bashing il faut
arrêter il faut arrêter tout cela le
mode ferrer comme j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est quand même une certaine
fiabilité
certes il ya des représentants des
usagers qui le dit c'est d'autant plus
important
oui et il ya des problèmes il est vrai
qu'il ya des problèmes qui se dégrade à
sion du service des trains qui arrivent
de moins en moins à l'heure aujourd'hui
typiquement les chiffres de vendredi
dernier sur les ter en bourgogne franche
comté 91 % de trains sont arrivés à
l'heure en bourgogne franche comté ça
c'est vendredi un chiffre qui sont tout
à fait officielle aujourd'hui puisque
cncf diffuse tous les jours via ses
comptes twitter et facebook
ces chiffres 91 % de trains à l'heure ça
veut dire qu'elle a un sur dix en
moyenne qui n'est pas à l'heure quand
vous êtes un navetteur donc quelqu'un
qui prend le train le matin le soir pour
aller au travail pour en revenir
ça veut dire que vous avez une chance
sur dix dans votre semaine d'avoir un
train en retard donc c'est ça qui
aujourd'hui c'est trop pour quelqu'un
qui prend le train tous les jours c'est
vraiment la vie est là il faut
effectivement une fiabilité et pour ça
il faut quand même un investissement de
masse havrais investissements sur le
réseau
et ça c'est ce qui manque depuis 20-30
ans il n'est pas normal aujourd'hui que
vous ayez encore des lignes en bourgogne
franche comté qui sont exploitées avec
système d'exploitation qui date de 1930
je prends l'exemple d'auxerre la roche
je suis désolé 1930 c'est plus du tout
adaptée aux besoins d'aujourd'hui 1930
michel
totalement d'accord mais je vais un peu
plus loin que cédric journaux
l'indicateur de retard par train ne veut
rien dire ce que ce qui est important ce
sont les clients les usagers combien il
convient non mais on a dit ce qu'on est
l'usure d'ailleurs combien sont en
retard l'indicateur qu'il faut prendre
et c'est ce que l'on va mettre dans la
nouvelle convention cantera d'été que
c'est avec la sncf c'est le nombre de
passagers qui arrivent en retard parce
que ce sont toujours les mêmes trains
qui sont des trains dit malade qui sont
des très sensibles et très naturellement
c'est en période de points que les
incidents arrivent le maillon faible est
toujours en période de pointe dire quand
il ya plus de traits qu'il ya plus de
monde quand le matériel est plus
sollicité eh bien vous envie ce que nous
envisageons déjà les indicateurs que
l'on prend pour mesurer doivent être
changées on doit avoir des indicateurs
c'est ce qu'on va mettre ou être la
première et je tiens d'ailleurs une fois
qu'elle vous disent qu'il ya des trains
qui arrivent en retard
l'opérateur qui toile sncf ou plus tard
un autre opérateur
si vous lui mettez un indicateur avec
des pénalités liées à la non réalisation
de cet indicateur
toute sa philosophie d'organisation sera
différent sur les lignes sur les le
réseau effectivement le réseau est dans
une situation où on continue de rouler
mais à des vitesses - dont vous faites
un grand travail pour mettre en
coordination tout les horaires et vous
apprenez qu'on est obligé de rouler à 30
à l'heure qu'à rentrer leurs épines
allure là nous concerne apple quand même
les régionales il va falloir mettre une
partie de ce réseau parce que il n'a pas
été entretenu parce qu'il n'y a pas les
moyens financiers pour le faire parce
que ce n'était pas la priorité mais t'as
40 km heure le train va mettre une demi
heure de plus comment voulez vous
attirez donc la première des choses à
faire et c'est ce qu'il ya où on a
beaucoup parlé du rapport spin est un
jouet attentivement le rapport du
conseil d'orientation d'infrastructures
alors seulement terme est essentiel et
massa
fondée la position du gouvernement est
essentiel
il faut au moins ils prennent le
scénario 2 avec des variantes
supplémentaires en tout cas le
gouvernement par la voix de son premier
ministre est très claire il n'y aura pas
de fermeture arbitres arbitraire des
petites lignes ça ça a été dit et
confirmé d'un discours du premier
ministre
effectivement ce qui a été dit c'est que
les sous investissement chronique depuis
des décennies a ralenti la vitesse
commerciale de déplacement des trains
pour des raisons de sécurité les freins
sont obligés de ralentir et donc
prennent du retard et ne sont pas
fiables
le gouvernement l'a encore répond par un
plan d'investissement important 3 5
milliards sur les dix ans qui viennent
ça veut dire que l'ensemble du réseau
sans priorité aux tgv mais bien sur
l'ensemble du réseau
c'est 10 millions d'euros par jour sur
10 ans qui seront investis dans la
rénovation des impressionnants cancers
de la vulve qui n'a pas encore pris
position gouvernement belge je te
renvoie il en agneau discours du 1er mai
donne en mille a pas encore pris
position sur le discours d'une
magnifique hors primes l'arrêt mais ce
que je connais bien le sujet n'a pas
encore pris position sur le scénario qui
sera retenu en matière de financement
par la fiq est l'élément déterminant
pour les petites in puisque c'est donc
cadre du contrat de projets état région
nous le faisons mais moi je pense
j'espère en tout cas position des
régions qui a demandé que ce soit au
mois le scénario intermédiaire bonifié
par débat avec ce l'ensemble des régions
qui soit choisi dix images
oui ça qu'on a d'autres à voir qu'il
faut être contrer la concurrence elle
n'est pas encore certain la souhaite
nous on la souhaite pas elle n'est pas
obligatoire
premier élément deuxième élément si on
veut parler effectivement de train
régulièrement retard y'a pas de problème
il ya pour cela des instances de
concertation les comités de ligne un
certain nombre d'instances qu'il faut
faire vite il n'existe plus mais qui est
voilà et qui fait qu'ils sont prévues
par la loi qu'il faut faire vivre
il faut faire vivre la démocratie au
plus proche sur en amont de ce qu'on
veut faire
avoir des décisions avec les usagers en
amont par en aval c'est pas des chambres
d'enregistrement s'ils sont bien là on
va recenser les besoins et qui est le
débat ensuite sur les trains en retard
va falloir poser la question des moyens
disponibles aussi bien en matériel qu'en
personnel vous dites les petites lignes
s'est pas complètement réglé c'est pas
parce que le premier ministre asie
quelle ne disparaîtrait pas qu'elles ne
vont pas disparaître je vous propose de
regarder la carte du rapport spinetta
dans notre région
cette carte elle montre plusieurs lignes
je pense à cravans avallon par exemple
qui a une très petite fréquence jean
cyril spinetta 10 45% du réseau ne voit
passer que 2 % des voyageurs oui c'est
vrai et alors est ce que vous pensez que
ces lignes ont un avenir où ils ont un
avenir
je ne pense pas qu'il faille comparer
systématiquement on ne peut faire
circuler des circulations que s'il ya
des voix qui existe il ya un réseau qui
existe
on est dans une stratégie de réseau à
partir de là on est sur un développement
de l' usage il faut regarder au
développement des usages à l'heure
actuelle comment on fait du report modal
si on n'a pas le réseau pour ce faire
donc il faut un prendre le réseau et
ensuite essayer de le faire monter en
usage soit à saturation soit en usage il
ya des moyens différents
ensuite faut que le contexte législatif
et réglementaire s'y prête c'est à dire
qu'à l'heure actuelle va falloir
regarder les problèmes les positions des
uns des doutes sur comment on réalise ce
report modal
c'est effectivement c'est compliqué vous
vous êtes inquiets pour nos petites
lignes je suis inquiet dirais que je
suis attentif à ce que fera le
gouvernement ce que feront également les
régions parce que les petites lignes
concernent principalement les régions
est vrai que ça sera source une action
politique a l'impression que la balle
est dans le camp des régions d'ailleurs
quand on écoute le pré ministre les
régions sont pas tout seul quand même
parce que le financement après en
particulier infrastructures revêt aussi
un financement d'état vers la première
boutique des pipelines aujourd'hui c'est
que malheureusement la polyvalence de la
sncf n'est pas n'a pas été mise en place
ce qui fait que vous avez sur ses
petites mains des coûts qui sont
beaucoup plus importants de la part la
sncf que pour l'être un autre opérateur
nous avons un certain nombre d'exemples
en france je dis bien en france 2
compagnie ferroviaire type ok au lit ce
type cft a en bretagne qui font un coût
de 8 à 9 euros du kilomètre pour un
transport ferré alors que la sncf est
plutôt due aux ordres de 21 20 21 21 22
euros du kilomètre alors rien que ça ça
vous pose la problématique se dire voilà
on peut comme continue à faire circuler
un train à moindre coût j'aimerais qu'on
aborde comme la question du statut des
cheminots didier martin on a
l'impression que le gouvernement veut en
faire un symbole vous allez me dire non
mais quand on écoute le président de la
république c'était il ya quelques jours
au salon de l'agriculture
dire je peux pas dire vous voyez bien
que je peux pas dire à un agriculteur
qui fait des horaires de fous qu'eux il
va prendre sa retraite en même temps que
les cheminots évidemment qu'on a
l'impression qu'on est du symbole alors
le sondage réalisé par harris
interactive le 26 février dernier pour
la fin du statut des cheminots dit que
69 % des français sont pour et 31 %
comptent donc vous avez plutôt l'opinion
publique avec vous mais est-ce que vous
montez pas les français les uns contre
les autres
non pas du tout moi je pense à dijon
histoire de dijon et été marqués par
l'histoire du chemin de fer ça à
transformer complètement le destin de
cette ville et nous avoir eu une forte
population qui est en rapport direct ou
indirect avec les cheminots
ils ont des contraintes ils ont ils ont
rempli leur mission de service public
ils doivent évoluer dans des parcours
professionnels ils doivent évolue aussi
avec la révolution des techniques n'est
plus normal de faire du contrôle à pied
alors qu'on peut mettre en place des
caméras automatiques pour détecter les
les anomalies d'infrastructures cette
profession elle a rendu ses services ses
contraintes
on peut en parler sa science du dialogue
si le sens du dialogue ouvert par le
ministre comment évoluer avec ses
contraintes et ouverture pour les
nouvelles recrues un statut du code du
travail général j'ai envie d'entendre à
michel neugnot d'un mot vraiment parce
qu'on arrive au terme de cette émission
sur cette histoire de statut des
cheminots
le parti socialiste n'a jamais voulu le
transformer le rénover vous en pensez
quoi
sur le statut des cheminots là notre
position est claire déjà il ya deux
parties il ya les cheminots qui sont un
exercice où n'est pas question de
remettre en cause le statut il ya des
nouveaux qui vont à renier leur ont par
contre sur la méthode sûre
méthode sur la méthode nous sommes en
total désaccord sur la stigmatisation
qui était fait et notamment dans les
propos tenus par le premier ministre qui
opposait la dette au statut des
cheminots
j'invite non ce n'est pas lié parce que
dans un cas vous êtes dans un
investissement de structures qui amène
de la dette est dans un autre cas un
travail d'exploitation où il n'y a pas
de dette au niveau des fondations mais
il n'a jamais opposé cela c'est les
politiques dans les dents les propos je
mens pas je vais vous redonnerez le
verbatim je voudrais a gardé un sens
vers martine par rapport à l'effacer
cause ce que je veux dire quand même
parce que le bashing contre la sncf
c'est une responsabilité partagée de
tout le monde la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes et je voudrais dire que il
n'ya il ya eu des gains de productivité
normes une modernisation qui s'est faite
aussi il n'ya plus que 140 mille
cheminots il était là quatre cent mille
à un moment donné on a eu un travail de
modernisation qui était fin prêt pas
qu'à travers ce débat il ya du bashing
temps sur le sujet le statut et que sur
la sncf n'est pas l'objet de visites on
a l'impression que c'est le principal
point de blocage pour vous les syndicats
de cheminots la question du statut des
nouveaux entrants on leur précise
vous avez reçu la visite de la ministre
des transports hier avant-hier par dons
éventuels vendredi elizabeth banks vous
at elle rassuré ou pas du tout celui
ment pas le cas dijon vous rencontre moi
je pars d'un principe fondamental à
travail égal salaire égal les conditions
d'exercice égal
moi je pense qu'on est dans une société
où il faut qu'on réfléchisse un peu à ce
qu'on fait et on vise le nivellement par
le bas
le nivellement par le bas si c'est le
type de société qu'on veut pour demain
va falloir y penser plus que
sérieusement et comprenez que nous en
tant que salarié il est hors de question
qu'on qu'on aille là dedans
le statut des cheminots 69% ont fait
état de sondages moi je veux bien
entendre tout et n'importe quoi
parmi les son nom mais c'est un sondage
je le prends comme tel pour autant
qu'elles sont les répondants qui ont
connaissance de ce qu'est le statut des
cheminots le statut des cheminots n'est
qu'une convention collective
c'est son statut de d'approuver par
décret du gouvernement qui lui donne cet
aspect statutaire ce n'est que tu ne
sont que des garanties collectives qui
sont la contrepartie de la contrepartie
de contraintes et un certain moment
si on veut enlever la contrepartie aux
contraintes falloir se poser la question
des contraintes on arrive au terme de
l'émission et compris des contraintes
financières on arrive à terme de
dimensions on voit bien qu'on sera
jamais en phase là dessus ça veut dire
que vous envisagez la grève dès jeudi
prochain
on va déjà attendre le blocage on va où
là
on va attendre on va attendre les
décisions on va attendre le 14 les
décisions du gouvernement le 15
les directions d'entreprise du groupe
public ferroviaire doivent aussi rendre
une feuille de route
les organisations syndicales au niveau
national se rencontreront pour l'instant
les seules choses qui sont décidés c'est
une manifestation nationale de
l'ensemble des cheminots à paris le 22
février avec et ensuite on entendra
qu'elles sont réellement les
orientations et on merci on verra bien
merci merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
accepté de répondre à ces questions et
de participer en direct à ce débat merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant le point sur l'actualité
régionale avec emmanuel pinsonneault
puis la partie nationale de dimanche en
politique avec francis letellier qui
reçoit jean luc mélenchon bon dimanche à
tous
[Musique]